first up he is the governor of Florida
who is wow currently on our show
currently running to be the Republican
nominee for president in 2024. Governor
Ron DeSantis
[Applause]
all right on a scale of nine to ten
what'd you think of my monologue
honestly I was laughing I'll give you
that right laughing on both sides of the
aisle too so it was good and welcome
back to the show I know you guys were on
Hiatus for a while thank you
it's yes
I do I do got to put in a plug like if
you ever have problems in California you
know in Florida not only we have no
income tax no vax mandates allowed in
the state well we're going to get to
that we're going to get to that
um
I know but people do wear cowboy boots
with a suit that's right so I'm not
going to fly okay that's uh that's just
a crazy thing I'm proud of it but there
were no cowboys in Florida Ron oh yeah
you should try Florida we're one of the
top cattle states in America you want to
go from the beach you go the interior
Florida nothing but cattle ranches oh
all right well I've I've I stand
corrected
thank you
because I'm wearing orthopedic shoes
there you go
okay so the debate it was a show
but I right I mean even you said you
wouldn't have you would have turned it
off if you were watching I mean people
screaming over each other I couldn't
hear what anyone would say it was
terrible but I heard you won I heard the
polling said you won what did you win
with Trump no honestly with Trump not in
the race what did you win well but I
think that you know he he's not showing
up he's missing in action he owes it to
voters to show up and defend his record
and I think he thinks he can take a
juice poll and then people don't get to
vote that's not the way the system works
you got to go earn votes so I'm showing
up I'm showing that and that's here's
the thing in the midst of all the show
that happened I was the one guy that
people said you know what this guy's
actually acting like a president when
the rest were not and so okay there I am
I told Donald let's do a debate I'm
debating your Governor Gavin we're gonna
get to that but let's do a debate with
me and him I'll do it all right but this
can I ask you one thing about these
debates can you get rid of this guy Doug
burgum
hahaha
this guy this bugs me he is not going to
be president this guy could start dating
Taylor Swift no one would care
North Dakota it's not even this day but
you know the thing is you did not take
my advice
what was it I was on this show a few
times we talked I said this guy's crazy
to run this time he's what are you 45
years old he just had a birthday right
yeah you could run for the next 20 years
if you were biting the next 40.
okay why run against Trump you're trying
to thread this needle that will never
happen well for a couple reasons you
can't you can't disavow him because you
that's the base and yet you're running
against him and that's why I mean let's
face it Ron if this if campaign was
going well you wouldn't be on this show
oh that's not true so
um one I don't think he can win the
election uh I could win the election two
I don't think he could actually get the
job done that we need to do for example
covid I think we need accountability for
what this government did to this country
with the coven restrictions mandates and
lockdowns Donald Trump is not going to
do that
he says he did everything right he says
he saved millions of lives with
lockdowns he claims his mnra shot saved
100 million lives he's not going to
clean house at CDC nihfd or any of that
I will do that I will get the job done
and a lot of other things we do the one
thing about me in Florida and even my
critics will acknowledge if he says he's
going to do something he will follow
through and get the job done so it's
about the country are we going to get
the country turned around or not I don't
think he's a vehicle that's doing and
and I have been when I supported them on
the things I liked I've said it but I've
been critical about the things that he
didn't do and I'll continue to do that
okay but you
but you campaigned for for election
deniers in 2022. this I do not forgive
well to quote the Godfather I I
Carrie Lake who said Biden's
illegitimate president
Trump didn't well now she's attacking me
so maybe I did make a mistake there
because uh she's out there saying she's
trying to say that we mandated vacs in
Florida we did the opposite we protected
people even from private mandates so so
that may have been Trump lost the
election right yeah yeah okay so why did
you campaign for people because I wanted
to see Republicans win Key races that's
not a deal breaker issue for you that's
not democracy okay well let's go back to
2016. uh your friends in Hollywood were
cutting ads telling the Electoral
College to to vote against Trump in in
the Electoral College because it was
stolen they said Russia stole the
election for years they said that so
don't act like this is like a unique
thing in modern history of the country
first of all Ron I have no friends in
Hollywood